Armin Laschet hat schon vieles erdulden
müssen von Markus Söder aber dass der
CSU-Chef den gegnerischen
Kanzlerkandidaten Olaf Scholz zum
Wahlsieger erklärt in beglückwünscht und
ihm quasi den Auftrag zur
Regierungsbildung erteilt könnte der
Schlussakkord einer permanenten
Demontage sein nach dem Wahl Debakel
Machtprobe in der Union jetzt in der
phönix-runde
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
zunächst hier im Studios an der
Schneider Chef Reporterin der Zeitung
die Welt und durch Deppendorf ist bei
uns ehemaliger Leiter des ARD
Hauptstadtstudios wo wir hier uns
befinden und heute Herausgeber des
hauptstadtbriefs zugeschaltet sind
Professor Karl Rudolf Karte
Politikwissenschaftler der Universität
Duisburg-Essen und Robin Blase ist bei
uns im Netz auch bekannt als Rob Bubble
sie sind Youtuber Podcaster Schauspieler
Moderator und sie haben vor der
Bundestagswahl einen Youtube Livestream
Model moderiert mit dem Titel in
Klammern unwählbar Deutschland was
stimmt nicht mit dir Fragezeichen
Ausrufezeichen
Herr Deppendorf ist die Union im Zustand
heilloser Verwirrung
im Moment bestimmt
zumindest in einem Zustand der
beklagenswert sein müsste für jeden der
die Union möglicherweise wählt nein was
wir heute erleben oder was wir erlebt
haben ist jetzt beispiellos auch heute
wieder
ein bayerischer CSU-Vorsitzender der
seinen eigenen panzerkandidaten im
Prinzip dieser voyiert
nieder macht letzten Endes sagt wo die
Post abgeht nämlich nur mit ihm und seit
heute ist klar Armin Laschet ist
abhängig von zwei Herren nämlich einmal
von eben Herrn Stoiber und der zweite
ist Herr Lindner und dann kommen noch
dazu Frau Werbung und der Habeck also
die Union ist in einer bedauernswerten
Lage
Frau Schneider ist Armin Laschet eine
tragische Figur ja sehr tragisch er kann
einem auch irgendwie nicht mehr leid tun
aber ich würde dazu sagen man kann ihm
schon sehr viel anlasten wenn man da
viel mitbekommen zum Wahlkampf die
Fehler die sich geleistet hat aber das
ist schon ganz grundlegendes Problem der
Union das ist irgendwie an ihm
ausgetragen werden in seiner Person also
da muss ich schon die ganze Truppe an
sich überlegen ob sie sich jetzt nicht
lieber kreativ zerstören will
macht Gespür Kompass politische Talente
wie viel ist davon eigentlich noch übrig
in der Union
die Union muss sich mit diesem Debakel
erstmal auseinandersetzen und das hat
sie vor der Wahl natürlich nicht gemacht
das bietet sich weil man Autosuggestion
betreibt und immer noch versucht auch zu
gewinnen und jetzt dauert das eine Weile
für so eine gefühlte Staatspartei eine
schwierige Rolle
merkellos und nicht Gewinner zu sein
das reist Wunden auf das macht
einzelne Machtzirkel wieder stark die
man gar nicht mehr kennt auf jeden Fall
kann nur eine Disziplinierung kommen von
einem Zug Richtung Jamaika das ist die
einzige Hoffnung um die
Unübersichtlichkeit zusammenzuhalten und
dieser Zug wird eben erkennbar schwer
abfahren
Robin Blase am Sonntag ist die Union ja
bei den jungwäldern abgeblitzt was macht
sie falsch
puh
ich glaube da ist da ist eine Menge
dabei
also ich glaube in den letzten vier
Jahren haben wir ja eine Menge Sachen
gesehen die junge Menschen aufgeregt hat
und auch glaube ich politischer gemacht
hat als je zuvor also sei das jetzt
Fridays for future oder sei das Artikel
13 die Diskussionen um die
Urheberrechtsreform und aber natürlich
auch rezo der vielen jungen Menschen
aufgezeigt hat was bei der Union in den
vielen Bereichen schief gelaufen ist und
ich glaube ja all das zusammen
Fluss vielleicht auch einfach 16 Jahre
Angela Merkel es gibt einfach eine
Regelung Menschen die eine andere
Bundeskanzlerin kennen dass da einfach
eine Menge Bedarf nach neuem ist und
nach Aufbruch und nach ja was anderem
als der
hat ja angekündigt quasi eine
zukunftskoalition gestalten Jamaika wird
sie auch oft genannt wie viel Zukunft
steckt da drin aus ihrer Sicht
also ich glaube dass eine Menge junge
Menschen
nicht gerne als Kanzler hätten ich
glaube ich wenn man sich anguckt
das zumindest Ampel und Jamaika die
beiden Sachen sind man sich anguckt das
war erst wieder ein FDP und dann die
grüne vorne lagen das ist schon mal was
positives also ich kann auch in Jamaika
was positives sehen wenn man mit bedenkt
dass sein Grüne und FDP mit regieren was
bei vielen jungen Menschen sicherlich zu
Freude führt aber das ist eine andere
Regierung eben auch der Fall und ich
glaube da können sich junge Menschen
aktuell noch ein bisschen mehr sehen
weil ich glaube einfach die Union da
nicht so punktet gut die Union ist
gewaltig abgeschmiert wenn man das mit
Wahlergebnissen früherer Jahresvergleich
gefühlte Staatspartei hat Professor
Korte gerade auch gesagt was ist denn da
jetzt nötig in dieser Situation wir
wissen noch nicht wie es jetzt
weitergeht kommt muss sie in die
Opposition das ist wahrscheinlicher
schafft sie doch noch die Kurve nach
Jamaika werden über diese
Konstellationen auch gleich noch genauer
sprechen aber was macht was wäre jetzt
sinnvoll mit der Union wie muss sie vor
allem die CDU reagieren ist da ein
harter Schnitt besser oder ein
moderierter Übergang
also ich glaube in der jetzigen
Situation der die CDU ist
würde ein harter Schnitt der richtiger
sein
wir haben eben die 16 Jahre Angela
Merkel gehabt
da muss man sagen ist die CDU auch immer
ihrer Kanzlerin gefolgt auf jedem
Parteitag also wer jetzt nur die Schuld
bei Frau Merkel ablehnt der macht sich
glaube ich auch ein bisschen zu einfach
aber die Partei hat jetzt eben so den
Zustand wie es verbraucht sie ist
zerstritten die Union ist zerstritten
und ich glaube da brauchen wir jetzt
paar jüngere und auch neue Leute an der
Spitze Herr März
geistert ja immer rum der könnte es
vielleicht auch aufrichten ich glaube im
März ist sicherlich nicht der Ausbund
für die Zukunft der Erneuerung 66 Jahre
ja kurz noch lange nicht Schluss mit 66
Jahren ist richtig das war mal ein Song
aber ich glaube die auch die jüngeren
Leute würden jetzt glaube ich von der
Union
lieber einen etwas jüngeren ja
Vorsitzenden Kandidaten möglicherweise
eine etwas jüngere Gruppe drumherum
warten als jetzt noch mal der Auftritt
der etwas älteren Herren da sage ich
selbst als älterer also von daher glaube
ich muss die Union sich schon jetzt
grundlegend erneuern es gab ja heute
auch Stimmen schon in der Fraktion ich
meine eine stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende fordert letzten
Endes den Rücktritt ihres
Parteivorsitzenden Gitta Connemann
Dieter konnermann das sind schon Sachen
die so ist in den letzten Jahren
überhaupt nicht gegeben hat bei Gerhard
Schröder oder Helmut Kohl nicht gegeben
ja wie lange diese Geschwindigkeit muss
jetzt in diesen
wandlungsübergangs oder Änderungsprozess
rein also es ist ja wirklich keine Frage
des ob mehr sondern nur das wann diese
Union einfach implodieren wird wenn ich
kann es tatsächlich nachvollziehen und
auch jetzt das irgendwie heute Herr
Dobrindt wieder gewählt wurde dass mir
jetzt quasi noch diese paar Tage
überbrücken möchte weil man kann ja wenn
man es hat einfach keinen Sinn jetzt zu
sagen wir sprengen uns in die Luft wenn
dann vielleicht doch noch Jamaika
möglich wäre also das kann ich
vielleicht noch nachvollziehen aber
jeder der das irgendwie beobachtet sieht
doch dass das einfach alles nicht mehr
in Ordnung ist und diese Partei einfach
wirklich am Ende ist und es gibt ja
schon noch ein paar andere Männer auch
in der oder vielleicht sogar Frauen die
vor allem nicht in diesem zukunftsteams
haben das spannende man hat sie mir
gefragt wer sitzt da nicht drinnen statt
wer sitzt drin so Jens Spahn oder
Carsten Linnemann also da gibt es schon
ein paar Menschen wo man sie denkt die
sind okay entspanne sind ein bisschen
verbraucht durch die coronakrise
natürlich aber Carsten Linnemann der ist
jung der hätte das glaube ich auch
irgendwie drauf ist aber in der Union
jetzt auch noch nicht so der einzelne
der Messias glaube ich jetzt mal aber
die werden wir noch genauer eingehen die
Namen die sie ja genannt haben aber
eigentlich man hat ja das Gefühl wieder
was man jetzt auch aus der
Fraktionssitzung da heute gehört hat
dass Armin Laschet nicht weichen will
genau es ist faszinierend also der hat
ein durchhaltungs durchhalten Vermögen
ist wenn dir wirklich spannend muss man
mir auch irgendwie ein bisschen
anrechnen da hat er einige Sachen
überlebt cdu-vorsitz durchgeprügelt
genau gegen Markus Söder ja da ist immer
sehr Frucht zu ihm aber
sich sogar Markus Söder an ihm die Zähne
ausgebissen hat genau immer nett dass
ich jetzt wirklich glaube aber es wäre
wieder mal der Witz der Geschichte wenn
Armin Laschet auch das wieder aussitzt
und dann enden wir doch bitte jamaika
ist gut die Frage ob das dieses Mal auch
für ihn positiv ausgeht Professor Korte
gibt es in der Union noch so etwas wie
eine ordnende Hand die jetzt eigentlich
ja dringend notwendig wäre die
Orientierung gibt die vielleicht auch
mal zur Besinnung ruft wenn man sich das
heute ansieht das war eine ein
vielstimmiger Chor viel Kakophonie gibt
es diese ordnende Hand noch
nein die sehe ich nicht die wär aber
notwendig also wo ist das strategische
Zentrum der Union wo ist das
strategische Zentrum der CDU wenn wir
uns an die letzten Monate spektakuläre
Nachtsitzungen erinnert dann haben
Schäuble und Bouvier offenbar sehr
wirkungsvoll noch eingewirkt um
bestimmte machtstrategische Elemente
nach vorne zu bringen das ist im Moment
nicht sichtbar es ist ein bisschen in
Auflösung begriffen Laschet scheint noch
zu vermuten dass er genügend Rest macht
hat um auch weitere Tage zu überstehen
um die Verhandlungen zu führen kann sein
aber es wirkt im Moment nicht so also
würdevoll bedeutungslos zu werden ist
eine große Kunst in der Politik das
haben nicht viele hinbekommen der
Zeitpunkt für ihn jetzt zu sagen es wäre
besser in die Opposition zu gehen ist
eigentlich verpasst insofern können das
nur neue Akteure machen in der Regel aus
der frisch gewählten Fraktion also
jüngere Frauen jüngere Männer die sagen
es ist auch eine gute Tradition durch
den Wähler entscheiden zu lassen wer ist
Regierung wäre es Opposition das macht
am Wahltag Sinn und die CDU wäre dann
die größte deutsche Oppositionspartei
auch eine ehrenvolle Aufgabe und diesen
Platz haben sie glücklicherweise ja der
AFD streitig gemacht die ja viel kleiner
geworden ist und einen Rand
Oppositionspartei quasi ist eine
besondere Stellung und man kann sich in
der Opposition nicht erneuern das ist
auch eine Floskel aber man kann
natürlich eine Regierung durchaus vor
sich hertreiben mit klugen neuen Ideen
und darauf sollten neu warten ich
erwarte wenn überhaupt ein Machtzentrum
dann aus der Fraktion hervorgeht nicht
aus dem konrad-adenauerhaus
Robin Blase wenn man sich jetzt ein
Machtzentrum vorstellt vielleicht mal
wieder mit einer ordnenden Hand wer
würde das eigentlich oder wir könnte das
sein denn wenn man sich diese Namen mal
sie haben sie vorhin ja auch zum Teil
schon während die entspannt
Kasten Linnemann Friedrich Merz wird
noch erwähnten aber trotzdem das sind
die haben alle eins gemeinsam so
unterschiedlich sie oft agieren und
vielleicht auch ihre politischen Inhalte
sind sind alles keine Teamplayer was
bedeutet das eigentlich wenn da eher
Leute unterwegs sind die so allesamt auf
eigene Rechnung arbeiten und dafür auch
bekannt sind
also ich fand das sehr faszinierend als
diese Debatte ja schon was ich vor der
Wahl als mal auf der Suche war nach
einem Spitzenkandidaten geführt wurde
und
keiner von denen also zumindest jetzt in
meiner Generation
groß Sympathiepunkte geerntet hat und
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht so aus der
Wahrnehmung also gerade so ein Friedrich
Merz oder so ob man die jetzt noch mal
auspacken kann also zumindest um in der
Generation in der ich mich jetzt befinde
irgendwie was umzudrehen also ich glaube
da hat man sich entspannen genauso auch
Kritik gehört
auch eine Norbert Röttgen also ich
glaube es war es war alles jetzt nicht
so
junge Menschen so aus meiner Bubble und
meiner Wahrnehmung in meiner Community
und so weiter irgendwie das Gefühl
hatten da ist jetzt irgendjemand den
finden wir cool den hätten wir gerne da
würden wir uns vielleicht dazu hinreißen
lassen die Union zu wählen ich glaube
die Person fehlt bisher also zumindest
aus meiner Wahrnehmung liegt das
vielleicht auch daran dass ja auch
Kasten Linnemann und Jens Spahn die
Jüngeren dieser Gruppierung gefühlt und
wahrscheinlich ist es so gar nicht so
weit weg von der Realität schon etwas
halbes Leben in der Politik zugebracht
haben trotz ihrer jungen Jahre
also tatsächlich was zum Beispiel einen
sparen wir auffällt diese diese ganze
Debatte um die corona-pandemie da haben
natürlich eine junge Männer junge
Menschen auch extrem drunter gelitten
wenn es darum ging so was sind was ist
jetzt mit meiner Schule oder was ist mit
meinen Freiheiten als junger Mensch
irgendwie feiern zu gehen und so weiter
wo natürlich da auch einfach viel glaube
ich kaputt gemacht wurde auch an
Vertrauen bei jungen Menschen
ich generell also auch bei jetzt sparen
gab es hier diese ganzen Geschichten mit
seinem Haus und dem dieser dieser großen
Dinner wo viele Geld bezahlt haben also
ich hatte im Zuge der war schon die wir
gemacht haben eine Umfrage gemacht in
meiner Community und hatte gefragt was
die sich zur Wahl von von mir wünschen
für Inhalte und die konnten frei
eintragen was sie wollten das zweit
meist gewünschte Thema war Korruption
und ich glaube das ist so eine Sache die
viele jetzt so mit Jens Spahn noch
weniger als mit seinen Kollegen
vielleicht aber auch in Teilen mit ihm
vielleicht verbinden
gut wir kommen gleich noch mal auf die
Fragen wie es jetzt weitergeht mit
Personal zurück also mit dem neuen dem
möglicherweise frischen Personal Ulrich
Deppendorf er will nicht weichen Armin
Laschet hat man das Gefühl wer könnte
ihm denn eigentlich sagen oder etwas ins
Ohr flüstern da gibt es ja einen in der
Union mit immer noch großer Autorität
der müsste ja nur einen Satz wiederholen
aus zwei Worten den der in sehr legendär
gemacht hat ich over also das heißt
Wolfgang Schäuble das wäre ja eine
solche Autorität muss so jemand jetzt an
ihn ran treten ich glaube Wolfgang
Schäuble wird es gar nicht mehr machen
können weil er bei derjenige der Laschet
sozusagen durchgesetzt
so jetzt hat den möglicherweise Laschet
enttäuscht ich glaube jetzt zu sagen ist
over das würde jetzt mal auch von
Wolfgang schäufel glaube ich kann nicht
mehr also ganz besonders gelungen
ansehen
da ist im Moment keiner der einzige der
ihm da sagen kann ist letztendlich er
selber oder seine Frau oder ich weiß
nicht wer oder eben eine massive Front
gegen ihn in der Partei und die ist ja
nach heute nach dieser Fraktionssitzung
jetzt zuerst mal etwas kaschiert worden
aber was haben wir denn erreicht der
bringt aus macht jetzt ein halbes Jahr
macht jetzt Fraktionsvorsitz weiter so
und dann haben wir eine Wahl und dann
was passiert denn wenn Herr Laschet
nicht Kanzler wird dann geht die ganze
Diskussion wieder von vorne los dann
will er nämlich den Oppositionsführer
machen er will den
Fraktionsvorsitzenden sicherlich haben
dann haben wir wieder in der Partei die
gleiche Auseinandersetzung und wir haben
keinen die oder keine die irgendwo
erkennbar da den Laden zusammenhalten
könnte das hat ja Professor Korte auch
gerade gesagt
ich meine ganz interessant ist ja wenn
man in die Geschichte hineingeht
die die jetzt so oft gescholtene Angela
Merkel war ja eine junge Frau die damals
einen alten an die Seite gedrängt hat
Helmut Kohl und mit Mut und mit einem
Zeitungsartikel so was haben wir im
Moment nicht mehr es sind viele
angepasste aber man sagt ganz kurz
zu verteidigt haben ich finde das schon
dass das eben wir hatten es vorher schon
das 16 jahre einfach zu lang ist also
die Frau hat ja
ich glaube alle vier Wahlen hatte die
Union eine strategische Mehrheit also
das heißt gegen die Union konnte keine
Regierung gewinnen
zusammengehalten hat und man es jetzt
eigentlich nicht wundern braucht wenn
deswegen Kartenhaus zusammenfällt weil
sie hat als Person die Macht
ausgestrahlt und auch die
Inhaltslosigkeit kaschiert bis großen
Teilen also und das etabliert sie halt
in 16 Jahren ganz hart und das habe ich
vorhin mit man kann nicht alles Armin
Laschet Anlassen wir sie verhalten hat
und jetzt verhält da kann man streiten
aber eben die ganze Union braucht uns
strategisches neu denken das ist ja
diese programmatische Lehre einfach
warum gab ja viele junge Leute sie
denken ja warum will ich die denn was
ist denn der Zukunft und Armin Laschet
kommt und sagt dann macht er seine
zukunftsregierung da muss man sich schon
fragen warum also was was ist denn da
jetzt bis jetzt 16 Jahre lang und warum
macht er das jetzt anders wir kommen zu
dem Thema modellisierung wie sie das aus
geht das mit der merkelinie weiter oder
kommt jetzt etwas anders noch dazu ein
Großteil der CDU-Mitglieder sind ja
Katholiken und wenn sich Katholik was
wünschen dann gehen sie in eine Kirche
kaufen einer zwei Kerzen stecken die auf
wie viel Kerzen braucht es das ist doch
noch zu einer Jamaika-Koalition kommt
oder anders gefragt ist das wirklich
noch eine Option also ich glaube so viel
Kerzen kann man gar nicht zählen aber
ich glaube es gibt viele Kirchen unserer
viele Kerzen na ich glaube nicht das ist
komplett vom Tisch ist aber eher in
dieser Variante das
sich wenn sich gelb und grün einigen
wovon jetzt mal ausgehe weil die wollen
das und Sie müssen es eigentlich auch
weil sonst droht war es am Ende die
große Koalition ist es ja wirklich der
absolute Horror für alle Beteiligten
also nehmen wir an Grün und Gelb einigen
sie und suchen sich dann ihren Kanzler
aus und werden wahrscheinlich eben das
erste zu Olaf Scholz gehen sollte das
Krach entscheiden was vielleicht
passieren könnte wenn sie draufkommen
dass die 50 Users die jetzt Herrn Scholz
im Nacken sitzen doch ein bisschen mehr
wollen also so jetzt von sich gibt kann
ja passieren dann wird Jamaika eben noch
immer ein bisschen eine Möglichkeit und
deswegen finde ich auch jetzt nicht ganz
dumm von der Union zu sagen wir halten
jetzt mal still und schauen also es ist
eine komplett vom Tisch aber halt für
sehr unwahrscheinlich weil ich schon
glaube dass Herr Scholz alles tun wird
um das zustande zu bringen die Ampel
Professor Korte wenn es diese wenn diese
Ampelkoalition nicht zustande kommen
sollte
kann denn dann eine Jamaika-Koalition
zustande kommen weil inhaltlich wird sie
sich ja doch nicht so sehr unterscheiden
sie haben dann zwar eine andere
Kanzlerpartei aber ist das nicht ein
Hinweis darauf dass möglicherweise bei
Optionen dann nicht funktionieren Ampel
und Jamaika und dass das dann relativ
schnell wieder Richtung groko gehen
könnte
das ist nicht auszuschließen wenn die
citruskoalitionspartner ist überreizen
kann es wieder dazu kommen groko Modelle
durch zu denken vermutlich dann aber
ohne Laschet mit dem Kanzler Scholz an
der Spitze und wenn das bis dahin sich
blockieren sollte könnte man sich auch
wieder vorstellen dass man in Schloss
Bellevue einbestellt wird und der
kanzlermacher versucht diesen Knoten
wieder zu durchtrennen aber ich möchte
noch mal daran erinnern dass es
grundsätzlich möglich ist und nach
möglich sein sollte gegen eine
Mehrheitsfraktion eine Regierung zu
bilden einen Kanzler mehr Team zu
bekommen das ist schon dreimal in der
Geschichte erfolgt es ist nicht
unwahrscheinlich so etwas zu machen ist
auch nicht moralisch verwerflich es ist
einfach zugelassen weil wir zwei
verschiedene wahlakte haben einmal
Parlament und einmal Kanzlerwahl nur
waren diejenigen die das gemacht haben
starke Akteure sie hatten den Rückhalt
in ihre eigene Partei und dieser
Rückhalt schwindet ja offen von Tag zu
Tag und deswegen stellt sich vielleicht
auch gar nicht mehr lange die Frage ob
die
citrus-koalitionspartner jetzt mit
Schwarz verhandeln oder mit rot
verhandeln und sich eine neue junge
bürgerliche Mehrheit suchen sondern es
kann eben sehr schnell sein dass das
keine Option mehr ist sondern dass sie
sich vielleicht schneller auch mit der
roten Option anfreunden dann wird die
Zustimmung zu Laschet ja sofort bröckeln
wenn das so die Macht Optionen nicht
mehr sichtbar ist wird die Fassade
zusammenbrechen dann bin ich ziemlich
sicher und dann wird er auch von der
Position vertrieben nicht nur zu
verhandeln sondern ich rechne dann auch
damit dass jüngere in der Fraktion sich
an die Fraktion Spitze setzen wollen und
dieses Kapitel neu schreiben ist ein
Kipppunkt dann in der machtkonstruktion
Robin Blase diese
zitrus-koalition das heißt also rot in
schön und grün und gelb also die Grünen
und der FDP das sind ja die Darlehens
der jungen Wählerinnen und Wähler nach
dem Wahlergebnis haben die ja sehr gute
abgeschnitten würden haben sie ja gerade
gesagt wird ein ja lieber mit also
würden das die jungen Menschen
wahrscheinlich eher sehen mit einem
Kanzler Scholz einen als einem Kanzler
Laschet geht es da um Inhalte also eher
bürgerliche oder eher linke Inhalte oder
ist einfach
Olaf Scholz der mit Abstand coolere
Kanzler der auch vielleicht ein
Lebensgefühl der U30 oder U20 besser
bedient
also ich glaube nicht dass die Präferenz
was damit zu tun hat das Olaf Scholz für
junge Menschen
[Musik]
Jünger rüberkommt ich glaube dass hat
auch nicht unbedingt was mit mit
linkeren Werten zu tun ich glaube es hat
einfach damit zu tun dass die Union dass
wir eben auch sagen von 16 Jahre angela
Merkel ist einfach sehr lange und eine
Menge junge Menschen
kennen nur das und haben aber das Gefühl
in den letzten 16 Jahren ist es nicht
unbedingt besser für sie geworden oder
der Blick in die Zukunft sei es jetzt
Themen wie Digitalisierung oder auch
Klimawandel sind eben Dinge die in den
letzten 16 Jahren vielleicht ein
bisschen verschlafen wurden und da ist
glaube ich was anderes besser und ich
glaube da vergessen viele dass die SPD
da auch teilweise mitregiert hat in der
Zeit aber ich glaube das ist sozusagen
auch Teil der Message also das Gefühl
oder Scholz ist einfach was anderes als
bisher auch wenn das so halb stimmt
ich glaube was junge Menschen vor allem
wollte dass ihre Inhalte durchgesetzt
werden da müssen sie glaube ich vor
allem auch auf die gewünschten
ich glaube die jungen Menschen wollen
einfach das ich sag mal rot das die
citrus-koalition dabei ist so und
hinzu kommt dann das glaube ich dass sie
davon der Koalition der Ampelkoalition
auch mehr erwarten ich sehe das genauso
also ob Olaf Scholz da könnte auch
vielleicht noch ein anderer sitzen
aber er ist es nun mal er ist ja fast
schon ich habe noch mal gesagt die
männliche Merkel der SPD also so großer
Unterschied ist ja von dem Temperament
da gar nicht aber er spricht glaube ich
eben auch und das war für mich auch
interessant nicht nur die Jungen sondern
der Scholz hat auch und die SPD viele
der älteren Wähler jetzt bei dieser Wahl
gewonnen da sind viele auch der
65-jährigen sind sogar zur SPD rüber
gegangen also da ist eine eine
Gesamtstimmung da die einfach sagt ja
nach 16 Jahren wird
würde man vielleicht dann doch wieder
bei der groko diesmal unter der Führung
von Olaf Scholz landen das ist ich halte
das nichts für ausgeschlossen ich halte
bei dieser Wahl überhaupt nichts für
ausgeschlossen
selbst ein eine Neuwahl halte ich auch
nicht mehr für ausgeschlossen
das muss man einfach sagen dann kommt
sicherlich was Professor Korte ja schon
gesagt hat ist auch darauf an
möglicherweise was dann der amtierende
Bundespräsident möglicherweise wenn
nichts anderes sagt als vor vier Jahren
nach dem Motto also es wird hier gewählt
sondern braucht euch zusammen ja alles
möglich also es gibt bitte
ja was ist eben aus diesem Ergebnis
eigentlich ableitbar wir haben eine sehr
bunte Mitte die uns auch von in der
Breite von vielen anderen europäischen
Ländern unterscheidet die Extreme sind
viel kleiner geworden als vorher aber es
ist jetzt klar dass die vier etwas
gemeinsam machen sollen aber es ist
diese Unentschiedenheit die wir
eigentlich dokumentieren die Buntheit 7
Parteien mit diesen Schleswig
dänischen Minderheiten noch dabei wir
haben eben diese veränderungs
Euphorie genauso wie Status Quo und es
soll so weitergehen wie bisher diese
Unentschiedenheit hat sich am Wahltag
auch gezeigt sonst wäre das Ergebnis ja
klarer wir haben ja zeitgleich in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern teilweise auch in
Berlin ganz klare Ergebnisse mit 30 und
an die 40 Prozent Parteien wie bei
anderen Landtagswahlen auch diese
Klarheit lässt sich eben aus dem
Ergebnis nicht Zeit aber es liegt an uns
an Wählerinnen und Wähler wir haben
keine Klarheit gewählt sondern eher so
etwas wie eine stabile Ambivalenz der
Uneindeutigkeit und aus dieser
Uneindeutigkeit müssen die Parteien vier
Parteien etwas machen das ist auch nicht
einfach
und Schneider immer noch mal zu Markus
Söder es gibt ja in der CDU
wahrscheinlich einige da unterstellen
wir jetzt niemanden etwas gesagt wenn
man so ein Parteifreund hat dann braucht
man eigentlich keine Gegner mehr wie ist
denn die Rolle so dass zu sehen in den
nächsten Wochen Monaten eher schwingt
sich ja auf zum zum Richter
vergibt Haltungsnoten die sogenannte
B-Note natürlich auch was die Inhalte
angeht wie wird er da in den nächsten
Wochen und Monaten agieren können würde
diese Rolle durchhalten können als der
eigentlich starke Mann der gesamtunion
das hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen
davon ab wo die Union jetzt landet im
Bundestag bzw in der Bundespolitik ob in
Opposition oder Regierung wie schätzen
Sie die Rolle von Söder ein bisher hat
er ja immer den starken Mann ganz gut
spielen können in der Öffentlichkeit
können weiß ich nicht aber wollen
zumindest ja also man glaub der ärgert
sie gerade grün und blau über ganz viele
Dinge und wir haben den Wankelmut seines
Charakters im Wahlkampf sehr gut
nachvollziehen können also da hat eine
Test jetzt auf Amelia eingedroschen
sondern macht es ja ein regelmäßig
Abständen und sagte einerseits so
absurde Sachen wie die Union müsse
regieren um sich in der Regierung zu
rehabilitieren quasi was eigentlich sehr
absurd ist jetzt aber eben heute haben
sie ja schon gesagt sagte im gleichen
Satz quasi das eigentlich schon Olaf
stolz sitzt Kanzler werden wird
wahrscheinlich es ist ganz absurd also
der fürchtete offensichtlich auch sehr
um seine eigene Macht klar oder Sie
haben er hat auch nicht gerade
glorreiche Zahlen eingefahren mit der
CSU abgesehen davon sind in den zwei
Jahren wird in Bayern gewählt also der
muss jetzt eigentlich alles drauf setzen
dass er die Verantwortung von sich
wegschickt und klar macht das war
aminarschütz schuld und dann in vier
Jahren kann er dann wieder der weiße
Ritter sein und das ist glaube ich eher
sein Plan also es wundert mich gar
nichts er macht ja eigentlich also immer
macht nämlich Markus söder-bing Markus
Söder und er will jetzt einfach schauen
dass er da entwickelt hinaus kommt
wieder kommt Markus wieder
möglicherweise mit Olaf Scholz als
Kanzler auch viel besser zurecht
einerseits was dem Gegensatz angeht also
als Kontrahent andererseits so auch im
Umgang liegt in der Typ Scholz mehr ich
halte das nicht für ausgeschlossen wenn
er sich aber da nicht vertut weil Olaf
Scholz ist schon einer der macht zwar
sehr auf zurückhaltend und er
hanseatisch aber der ist schon in vielen
Teilen auch beinhart also das wird eine
hochspannende würde eine hochspannende
Auseinandersetzung zwischen den beiden
aber
das ist ja wahrscheinlich die einzige
Chance noch vielleicht sogar noch für
die Union auf die auch Söder nun
kapriziert sich kapriziert er merkt mit
Armin Laschet wird das nicht mehr so und
er muss diese Rolle jetzt übernehmen
auch für sich selber dass er
vollkommen richtig gesagt denn auch die
Bayern selber machen Druck auch aus
seiner eigenen CSU kommt der Druck
nachdem er an die Seite geschoben worden
ist damals bei der Kanzlerkandidatur
jetzt muss er zeigen dass er diese
Bayern hoch hält und die CSU hochhält
und das hat heute begonnen das fand ich
was er heute gemacht hat eigentlich
bisher beispiellos er Blase wie sehen
Sie denn Markus Söder oder wie sehen
junge Menschen Markus Söder der ja sehr
medienaffin ist der nutzt alle Kanäle
linear digital erst überall vertreten
ständig
etwas eines ständig präsent in der
Öffentlichkeit ja etwas was der
Mediengesellschaft entgegenkommt im
Internet brummts und da ist Markus Söder
fühlt sich ja wahrscheinlich auch wohl
wie wie ist diese Rolle zu sehen oder
wie sieht man ihn als einen
möglicherweise zukünftigen oder
zukunftsträchtigen Politiker einfach
aufgrund seines Auftretens
also ich würde jetzt schon sagen dass er
meiner Meinung nach
besser aufgetreten ist als Armin Laschet
dass er auch in der Pandemie in Bayern
eine bessere Rolle gespielt hat als eine
Laschet in Nordrhein-Westfalen auch
vielleicht für jüngere Menschen die
da einfach Rechte besseres Gefühl hatten
aber ich also ich habe auch das Gefühl
dass gerade jetzt zum Beispiel bei den
jungen Menschen die jetzt die Grünen
vorne gesehen haben bei der FDP weiß ich
nicht aber bei den Grünen ich glaube die
haben auch
Respekt davor dass Söder schon sehr
konservativ ist und das vielleicht nicht
eine Sache ist die Sie unbedingt sehen
wollen also so toll war der Auftritt von
den Söder in der Pandemie auch nicht
die große Nummer gemacht und aber in
seinem eigenen Land hat er ziemlich hohe
Zahlen gehabt die waren fast identisch
mit denen in Nordrhein-Westfalen das ist
immer schön kaschiert worden von ihm
also da hat er eigentlich keine Punkte
sammeln können er sie nur besser
verkauft
auch gemeint dass seine Präsenz
natürlich groß war und die verkaufe
wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich gut ich
finde es überhaupt nicht gut verkauft
das war schon Grenze schon teilweise
autoritäre Maßnahmen sagt ich bin Team
vorsicht aber ganz hart und also damit
hat er hohe Zustimmungswerte mit den
jungen glaube ich eigentlich eher nicht
nichts andersrum empfinden das Armin
Laschet der ja eh schon immer der
Wartezeit Eröffnung als jetzt alles
schließen hatte sie auch so eine schief
eingezogen keine Frage aber meiner
Meinung nach würden doch junge Menschen
dann eher Söder abstoßend finden oder
der du sollst wirklich da der brutale
Landesvater daher kommt als allen
erklärt wie wir corona-politik machen ja
das ist ja die Frage Robin Blase ist es
der der moderiert der ausbügelt der die
ganzen Unwuchten sozusagen ja weg macht
glättet ist der der eigentlich der
Politiker der Autorität versprüht oder
der der so auch die Ecken und Kanten hat
und für Stimmung und Unterhaltung auch
sorgt
also mein persönliches Gefühl ich wohne
jetzt auch nicht in Bayern sondern in
Berlin ich habe das beides auch überall
in Deutschland gesehen gab ja zum
Beispiel Videos von wieso die explizit
auch Armin Laschet kritisiert haben zum
Beispiel für für das Thema Schule das
ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen her
und es gab noch weitere Aussage auch für
eine Lasche die zumindest in den
sozialen Medien großbreit getreten wurde
wo auch so ein bisschen ja das
im vorgeworfen wurde er würde die
Wissenschaftler nicht so richtig
respektieren ist aber eine Sache die die
weite Kreise zumindest bei mir in der
Community gemacht hat wo man eher das
Gefühl hatte okay Söder ist da
vielleicht ein bisschen härter und ich
kann mir auch sehr gut vorstellen dass
eine Menge junge Menschen in Bayern auch
sich geärgert haben dass sie nicht
irgendwie rausgehen können feiern können
was auch immer aber vom Gefühl her was
ich so in meiner Community gespürt habe
hat er in der Wahrnehmung und in der Art
und Weise wie er das vielleicht auch gut
kaschiert hat eine bessere Figur gemacht
als Armin Laschet der eher so wie ja
planlos und manchmal vielleicht auch so
ein bisschen
wissenschaftlich fehlgeleitet daher kam
in der all dem was wir hier besprechen
geht es ja vor allen Dingen auch um die
Zukunft der Union was macht sie jetzt
aus dem aus der Situation die sie
vorgefunden hat bzw sicherlich auch
verursacht hat mit diesem desaströsten
Wahlergebnis Professor Karte wir haben
über Angela Merkel gerade schon
gesprochen wohin wird sich denn die
Union inhaltlich bewegen wird sie den
Modernisierungskurs von Angela Merkel im
Prinzip fortführen wir kennen ja die
wählerwanderungen vom Sonntag sie die
Union hat ganz besonders Richtung SPD
und Grüne verloren weniger Richtung AFD
da hat sie ja sogar noch Wähler bekommen
60.000 insgesamt bei der Bundestagswahl
also wird sie diesen Modernisierungskurs
Fortführen der ja durchaus erfolgreich
war in 16 Jahren sonst könnte man sich
die Wahlerfolge von Angela Merkel nicht
erklären oder wird sie das tun was viele
in der CDU so im Mittelbau und
funktionärsapparat fordern doch wieder
mehr
konservatives traditionelles nationales
wirtschaftsliberales in den Vordergrund
stellen
naja ein Teil der plötzlichen
Wunderheilung der SPD hing ja damit
zusammen dass sie geschlossen sind
hinter Scholz man hat fast den Eindruck
eine Liste Scholz existiert und die
anderen beteiligen sich unterstützend
aber man hört von den anderen nichts und
es wurde eine die sogenannte Respekt
Erzählung entwickelt was durchaus
bedeutet Lebensleistung stärker in
Zentrum zurück um den Begriff der Arbeit
herum also klarer kann man nicht
herausarbeiten an Alleinstellungsmerkmal
zu haben was die weder auch massiv im
Osten beispielsweise für die SPD
beigetragen haben wenn wir das jetzt so
sehen dann muss man bei der Union nicht
auch wunderhaltung sofort setzen aber
die Voraussetzung ist durchaus wieder
ein Zentrum zu entwickeln und eine
Programmatik die nicht unbedingt nur von
den Mitgliedern getrieben sein muss
sondern durchaus sich am Wähler
orientiert Mitglieder sind immer
konservativer in allen Parteien und
insofern wäre das vermutlich ein Weg der
wenn man den konser halben Weg so wie
sie in
dargestellt haben erstmal kurzfristig
Mitglieder befriedet aber auf dem
wählermarkt nicht wirklich realisiert da
brauchen wir mit Sicherheit eine andere
Angriffsfläche die auch von einer
Erzählung ausgeht die man erst mal
entwickeln muss die freiheitserzählung
haben die
Liberalen und haben auch die Grünen für
sich entwickelt und neu entdeckt welche
Erzählung wäre das die die Union für
sich in Zentrum rückt dass sie im Moment
wie eine Regierung ohne Erzählung wirkt
eine Regierung eigentlich ohne Grund
dass sie nur Krise kann und das gut kann
reicht nicht aus man muss also ein neues
profiliertes
Alleinstellungsmerkmal entwickeln was
nicht einfach ist in dieser Gesellschaft
wenn sich parallel mit den
Zitrusfrüchten ist das ja angedeutet in
der Metapher eine junge neue
Bürgerlichkeit einen Weg bahnt wo ist in
der bürgerlichen Lage Platz
bestimmte Werte um eine soziale
Marktwirtschaft beispielsweise herum zu
kreieren danach muss sie suchen und das
bietet Möglichkeiten auch mit dieser
Erzählung als eine
führungsmöglichkeit auch neue wieder
anzuziehen aber ich glaube die
Grundsatzentscheidung muss fallen macht
man jetzt eher konservative
herangehensweisend stark die Mitglieder
lieben oder orientiert man sich gleich
auf dem wählermarkt dann wäre es breiter
angelegt Ulrich Deppendorf und glaube
ich ganz wichtig ist erstmal die
Umgebung brauchen wir wieder eine
Geschlossenheit ich meine der Erfolg von
von Olaf Scholz war ja seit einem Jahr
da ist eine geschlossene SPD während wir
bei der Union der letzten Endes nichts
anderes hatten als ein Jahr oder ein
dreiviertel Jahr Krieg zwischen
Armin Laschet bei anderen untereinander
erstmal aus der Union und dann mit Herrn
Söder das hat glaube ich auch viele
Wähler abgestürzt
geturnt sozusagen und dann zu diesen
desaströsen Ergebnis geführt
Geschlossenheit und eine Erzählung ja
oder ein ein Thema für die Zukunft das
ist das was die Union jetzt braucht ob
sie das dann mit Herrn Söder schafft
oder mit einem oder ein mehr jüngeren ja
da haben wir paar Namen genannt aber so
viel sehe ich da im Moment nicht
der Wurm muss ja den Fisch schmecken und
nicht dem Angler das was jetzt Professor
Kate da gerade angesprochen hat also das
was die funktions- und Mandatsträger der
Parteien die eher konservativ sind und
was die potenziellen Wählerinnen und
Wähler wünschen und die Sorgen ja für
die politischen Zukunft einer Partei ist
das der erfolgsversprechendere Weg auch
für die Union diese modernisiert diesen
Modernisierungskurs von Angela Merkel in
Antrag Form mit anderer Ansprache mit
anderen Personen mit einem anderen ja
mit einer anderen politischen Kultur
anzusprechen
mag das gar nicht hinterfragen jetzt ob
es wirklich alle Funktionäre auch
tatsächlich viel konservativer sind als
die Wähler aber trotzdem wenn man
von die Union hat sich
sozialdemokratisiert über die Jahre dass
wir die unterschreiben also und das kann
man auch so feststellen deswegen ist es
ja alles eine sehr große Suppe gerade so
grün schwarz rot also das ist alles sehr
ähnlich ich bin weit davon entfernt den
Konservativen zu sagen wie sie ihre
Politik aufzustellen haben aber das ist
ein bisschen auf der Markt regelt oder
wenn die Menschen eine wirklich
konsolute Partei gar nicht mehr haben
wollen damit sie eh nicht mehr gewählt
aber gut dann wird die Union eines Todes
sterben ist so vernaf das ist er wieder
Wille aber zu sagen wir machen jetzt
noch mehr irgendwie sozialdemokratisch
Politik sie ja überhaupt keinen Sinn
dahinter weil man hatte gesehen was
jetzt passiert die Menschen will dann
halt Olaf stolz und die Grünen und die
gibt's schon wie gesagt es ist mir fern
jetzt ein Programm für die konservative
hinzustellen Modernisierung und
Sozialdemokratisierung das gleiche Robin
Blase hat ja das auch gerade gesagt was
junge Menschen erwarten also das heißt
dass sie ja eben gerade dieser
zitruskombination viel entgegenbringen
der FDP und der der den Grünen Professor
hatte sagt neue Bürgerlichkeit eine neue
Orientierung auf gesellschaftliches
Miteinander soziale Marktwirtschaft also
da gibt es dort durchaus eben blinde
Flecken schon mal Carsten lindemannsfeld
geführt jetzt unabhängig davon welche
Rolle wirklich spielen wird aber gibt es
schon ein paar jungen Kandidaten die
dieses Profil haben die eben
wirtschaftsliberal Denken in weisen das
sehe schon irgendwie Potenzial die
konservative sind als Liberalen aber
wirklich anders Sozialdemokraten also
das gibt es glaube ich schon und da
könnte man das wäre auch immer das wohl
den Fokus drauf legen würde müsste ich
es mir aussuchen vermutlich aber ja das
ist ja hingestellt wie man das jetzt
aufsetzt also ist nicht so ganz klar was
der erfolgsversprechendere Weg für die
Union ist zurück zu dem was sich fühle
viele wünschen vor allem in den
östlichen Landesverbänden auch in
einigen westlichen Landesverbänden oder
zu sagen wir müssen uns jetzt
möglicherweise in der Opposition ganz
neu überlegen wo es eigentlich hingeht
also dahinter ist ja auch erstmal die
Frage was ist eigentlich konservativ ja
so ist es jetzt das was im Sommer in
Teilen in den
Ostländern hin zu AFD gegangen ist ist
das konservativ kann es nicht sein so
ist konservativ Werte weitertragen zu
den Werten gehört das Klima gehört
vieles da glaube ich gehört in der
Wirtschaft welche Werte gelten war eine
Blase hat vorhin von der Korruption
gesprochen und ähnlichen Geschichten da
glaube ich braucht man jetzt deutlicher
Wortmeldungen in diese Richtung da
wollen wir reingehen das wollen wir
ändern
wir müssen noch mehr fürs Klima tun das
braucht auch die Union das wissen die
auch
aber es braucht halt jemanden der das
oder mehrere die das überhaupt nach
vorne tragen wir haben ja auch im
Wahlkampf der Union erlebt der da auch
gar nichts gemacht hat also ich glaube
das war einer der schlecht geführtesten
Wahlkämpfe die die Union seit
Jahrzehnten gemacht haben ich frage mich
immer warum eigentlich ein
Generalsekretär der auch mein die
Diskussion kommt
Professor Kate wenn man sich ansieht wie
die Ost- und die westlandesverbände der
CDU der CDU reagieren jetzt auf das
Wahlergebnis beziehungsweise welche
inhaltlichen Präferenzen sie schon vor
der Bundestags gezeigt haben der oscdu
sitzt die AFD im Nacken und das hat ja
die Wahl auch gezeigt in Thüringen und
Sachsen ist die AFD stärkste Partei hat
der CDU eine ganze Reihe von Wahlkreisen
weggenommen das heißt die haben ja ganz
andere
profilierungsabsichten als die CDU im
urbanen Liberalen Milieu westlicher
Großstädte wo sie ja auch wieder gerne
landen möchte teilt sich da das spaltet
sich da die CDU eigentlich auch in ihren
Absichten oder in ihren inhaltlichen
Akzentuierungen wie kann man das dann
wieder zusammenführen in einer
Gesamtpartei die ja früher
Parteivorsitzende wie Konrad Adenauer
oder Helmut Kohl virtuos geführt haben
und integrieren konnten man kann sich
kaum vorstellen dass die Absichten eines
ostlandesverbandes der CDU eines
westlandesverbandes der CDU in Zukunft
noch zusammen gehen können
ja sie haben das sehr sehr gut
beschrieben das ist letztlich der Erfolg
der Union gewesen steckt ja auch im
Namen drin eine aus einer
Sammlungsbewegung eine
integrationspartei zu machen die als
catch all Phänomen immer größer wurde
und am Anfang an fing eben konfessionell
einzusammeln Katholiken und Protestanten
und dann alle anderen auch das ist auch
eine Teil der Geschichte das föderale
Element ja mal weniger Flügel oder
Vereinigungen die stark sind und
besondere Kreise sondern die föderale
Konstellation die zusammenhalten war
immer sehr schwer und es gibt immer
Landesverbände in der Geschichte der
Partei die eben auch
für besondere stand also linke
sozialer als die CDU beispielsweise auch
unter dem Gesichtspunkt der katholischen
Soziallehre als die in NRW konnte man
gar nicht sein und so sehe ich das jetzt
auch in der Besonderheit des Ostens in
der anderen Abweichung als diese
unterschiedlichen haben die in den
regionalen Landesverbänden begründet
sind die aber weiter auseinander sind
als das in früheren Zeiten ist und
insofern ist das
integrationsweltmeisterschaftliche was
man heute an den Tag legen müsste das
Zusammenhalten schwer eigentlich ist
Laschet genau der Kandidat weil er das
vorgemacht hat er
definiert macht durch Moderation und der
ist ein
Integrationsfigur im Wahlkampf ist ihm
das schon nicht mehr geglückt und hat er
den Eindruck das Scholz die große
Integrationsfigur ist jetzt für die
eigene Partei aber der entscheidende
Punkt ist in der Tat das föderale
zusammenzuhalten was die Union stark
macht vielleicht muss man aber auch nach
einzelnen Landesverbänden noch mal
gucken nach Ministerpräsident
beispielsweise Daniel Günther der ja
Jamaika erfolgreich anführt auch ein
junger
Politiker für die Union der frisch
damals in dieses Amt reinkam kurz vorher
auch erst nominiert worden war
das auch mit bundespolitischem Anspruch
immer wieder benennt also hier ist auch
in den Ländern zu gucken welche neuen
Personen vielleicht für den Bund
aktiviert werden könnten die
sympathisch sind die offenbar
Landesvater Attitüden vermitteln und die
auch ein modernen Anspruch haben zu
integrieren in einer jamaika-formation
Jamaika hätte damit auch eine
modernisierungsanspruch also man kann
auch über Länder was gewinnen nicht nur
die Differenzen sehen zwischen Ost und
West und die sind nämlich wirklich groß
und Blase der Name Riso ist schon
gefallen hier in der Sendung das ist der
Mitbürger der Junge Mitbürger der sein
Hauptteil wunderbares Blau getaucht hat
und mit dem legendären Video über die
Zerstörung der CDU ja Aufmerksamkeit
erregt hat kann man da jetzt vielleicht
auch sogar von einer Selbstzerstörung
der CDU sprechen wenn Sie sich ansehen
was die Partei jetzt in diesem Jahr
wie sie Wahl gekämpft hat und was sie am
Ende abgeliefert hat
absolut also ich glaube dass
als ich da dass es eben angesprochen
wurde es ein ziemlich guter Punkt also
ich habe so ein bisschen mehr die
Perspektive von von jungen Menschen
wieso und ich wir sind gleich alt die
Leute die wir ansprechen sind auch alle
unter 30 meistens
und ich glaube was der Union da fehlt
ist dieses
zukunftsgerichtete also ich muss auch
sagen dass ich 16 Jahre lang jetzt
Angela Merkel auch wenn ich vielleicht
nicht immer mit Punkten der CDU überein
gestimmt habe als Kanzlerin doch immer
irgendwie geschätzt habe ich habe lange
im Ausland gelebt und wie Deutschland da
wahrgenommen wurde auch unter anderem
durch sie war immer super positiv und
dass dieses dieses immer gleiche dieses
stabile das ist eben das was jetzt junge
Menschen eben nicht mehr wollen und ich
glaube da gab es einfach viel zu wenig
Anknüpfungspunkte also allein im ersten
Triel diese diese letzte Ansprache von
Armin Laschet mit der winterveränderung
bläst uns ins Gesicht und mit mir
puste ich zurück es war nicht das was er
gesagt hat aber ungefähr so dass das war
die Stimmung junge Menschen wollen
was anderes sei es die Pandemie sei es
die drohende Klimakatastrophe ist
passiert einfach nicht genug und es ist
nicht genug passiert und ich glaube die
Union hat das mit was junge Menschen
angeht nicht genug Dinge geliefert wo
man das Gefühl hatte
da kommt irgendwas was mir als junger
Mensch hilft sei es jetzt irgendwie ich
kann mir keine Wohnung mehr leisten weil
die Immobilienpreise zu hoch sind oder
ich hätte gerne Internet zu Hause auf
dem Land und würde hätte gern den
Anschluss an die den Rest der Welt oder
eben ich hätte gerne einen Plan für das
Klima damit ich nicht irgendwann
darunter extrem leide so wir haben nur
noch wenige Sekunden an der Schneider
kurze schlusswort
zu dem was die Union auch im Anschluss
daran ja ich glaube das reason gar nicht
notwendig war weil aus ganz vielen
anderen Gründen aber ich glaube auch
dass die Union sich glorreich selbst
zerstört hat ja gut dann bedanke ich
mich bei einer Schneider bei Ulrich
Deppendorf bei Robin Blase bei Karl
Rudolf Korte liebe Zuschauer morgen
werden wir dieses Thema was hat uns die
Bundestagswahl alles beschert aus einem
anderen Blickwinkel ansehen die
kanzlermacher und die geht es morgen
worauf können sich FDP und Grüne einigen
jetzt folgt Felix der Tag mit Konstanze
abratzke natürlich ist das Thema Union
aber auch die konstituierten Sitzungen
der anderen
Bundestagsfraktionen bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]